JASON SILVA: The
philosopher Tolstoy
wrote about how,
in order to live,
man must find a way to connect
the finite to the infinite.
We need to form some kind
of kinship between ourselves
and the unfathomable
vastness of the cosmos.
We are star stuff,
said Carl Sagan.
We are made of atoms,
literally cooked
in the furnaces of dying stars.
And so, in many ways,
we are infinite.
Yet a psychologist,
Ernest Becker,
wrote, we are
nevertheless housed
in heart-pumping, breath-gasping
decaying bodies, simultaneously
gods and worms.
And so we need a bridge,
a conduit to the numinous.
And perhaps no
greater instrument
in the history of humankind
than the telescope
can provide this
cathartic bridge,
as it blasts open new tunnels
between the mind and the other.
Ross Andersen's dazzling essay
on the James Webb Telescope
reminds us that in
his metaphysics,
Aristotle called seeing
the noblest faculty of man.
Andersen goes on to describe
with requisite virtuosity
how the deep field images of
the universe taken by the Hubble
literally mainline all of space
and time in the optic nerve.
So that the Space Telescope
has downloaded space and time
into our eyeball.
Where as once we were
blind, now we could see.
He continues, through
the sheer aesthetic force
of its discoveries,
the Hubble has
distilled the complex
abstractions of astrophysics
into singular
expressions of color
and light, vindicating
[INAUDIBLE] beauty
is truth, and truth-- beauty.
And thus, allowing the layman to
witness the scope and grandeur
of the universe through
an unprecedented expansion
of human vision, something the
new James Webb Space Telescope
will take to a whole new level.
Andersen continues,
the telescope
has provided nothing less
than an ontological awakening,
a forceful reckoning
with what is--
because we get to witness
galaxies pinwheeling
in [INAUDIBLE].
Something happens to
us during these moments
of introspective contemplation,
drunk on awe, as we literally
get to contemplate space
and time on a scale just
shy of the infinite,
that enlarges
the boundaries of our being.
Astronauts have called
this the overview effect.
Neil deGrasse Tyson calls
it the cosmic perspective.
We get to move beyond
the self toward something
grander, more
majestic, ineffable.
And we chase these
experiences ravenously.
As Henry Wismayer wrote,
as spirituality wains,
experience is the
new faith, and we
are refugees from the mundane.
And so we shall
continue achingly
to resuscitate that sense
of humbling incomprehension,
so that we may say, ah yes,
I remember what I forgot.
In the words of
Nisagardatta, the other world
is this world rightly seen.